this is what it means to be a queen or
queen dumb is what these gals use uh
they make reference to the book uh why
men loved which I've covered in a press
podcast I think if you search on YouTube
Alpha and why man look I've covered that
um it's a pretty I'm not gonna get in
the details but it's a stupid read it
doesn't set women straight you know for
being honest and they're talking about
being the queen is non-negotiable it's
foundational queendom comes first not
second and I don't mean you can pretend
to be one you pick it to you make a blah
blah they've got all these strategies
here so
let's see with it I mean I'm not going
to read this level let's get into why a
queen knows her worth so a queen nose
down to her marrow that she is worthy of
the best things that life has to offer
her confidence is unshakable while she
experiences setbacks and makes mistakes
just like anyone else she believes
wholeheartedly in her ability not only
to bounce back but to grow from the
experience and become even better even
more capable sounds Noble doesn't it
rather noble cause uh for said Queens
today
um you know back in the the Middle Ages
there was only ever a king and a queen
or sometimes just a king or sometimes
just a queen or consorts perhaps but not
everybody could be one there's
there's hierarchies in society but we're
in we're in a period of time now where
women are telling each other that
um they can all be Queens right
the queen is aware of her greatest
potential and fulfills it
okay also sounds Noble which is capable
of fulfills her people's potential in
all areas of life she values personal
growth for the sake of its own
I'm true she's accomplished in a variety
of air and actually starting to sound
like a man right
areas and saviors for Success never rest
in her Laurels for too long she
understands her shortcomings and flaws
and always looking to improve herself
sounds Noble let's keep going a queen
lives a full vibrant life
her life is Rich with meaning and she
loves it to the fullest whatever that
means for her as an individual okay I
like vibrant women that's cool a queen
suffers no fools now it's getting
interesting she does not concern herself
with the opinions of those who do not
have that have not proven their
worthiness to her she does not give her
time to our energy to anyone who just
disrespects her or fails to acknowledge
her worth
so she's setting her worth apparently by
their definition
man doesn't decide what her worth is
man looks at a woman and says she's
beautiful she's not beautiful that's how
Society works
man says she's attractive she's not
attractive that's how culture works
right that's how Society works but um
you're not allowed to have an opinion
on her worth because she decides that
for herself based on the vibrant
lectures that we're getting over here
but it keeps going but it keeps getting
better
a queen does not know we've gone through
about four of these right now and we
have not heard anything about Queen
being feminine dressing nicely having
nice long hair manicured you know clean
you know
well-shaped hourglass shaped or anything
like that they've covered none of that
okay
uh the queen only couples with an equal
she does not consort with peasants or
princes but only other full-fledged
Kings in their own right she does not
use her power to elevate anyone else to
her status how many times have I said
women don't care about your struggles
they wait at the finish line and they
pick a winner
you know it's funny because I've seen
about four or five videos in the last
six months show up in my feed and like
Clips there's always some nerd from the
man of swamp that's like oh rich is
wrong about this and here's why and then
like everybody's like ah no rich is
right you're wrong
anyway uh she's not user power to
elevate anyone else to her status she is
not a king maker again women kind of
expect men to become something to make
something of themselves so
I mean there's some truths here for men
to pay attention to and listen based on
what their opinions are but I think
their opinions of themselves are a
little bit skewed we'll find out why in
a minute furthermore she's content to
rule alone until a worthy King comes to
rule by her side this is where the
little fluffy white doggies and the
kitty cats come into play and you know
the decorative Decor throughout the
house with
you know Eat Pray Love [ __ ] signage
in the kitchen or in the bathroom or so
you guys know what I'm talking about
like you've seen it like this is why you
have such a large contingent of women
today and you're going to see a video in
a little bit which I'm going to play for
you where they kind of push themselves
into this area where they're well I'm
single but I'm but I'm ruling alone
because I read this thing on the
internet that said one must rule alone
until a worthy King comes to rule by my
side as if she's going to get with
somebody that's equally the same as her
women like better we know that women's
hypergamous nature means they date a
cross but mostly up the socioeconomic
scale
it's not often that they'll settle for
somebody that's an equal
let's keep going Queen never debases
herself for another she'll never lower
her standards for the benefit of someone
else nor will she compromise her beliefs
to Curry favor with another she has no
need to do such things because why she
has so many options this is why there's
so many single women into their 30s and
40s with cats and dogs
I'm telling you guys there is perhaps a
good investment opportunity in uh pet
food
you know Queen never shies away from the
truth no matter how well she's shining
away from the truth that women are
Beauty objects isn't she
no matter how difficult I mean we want
agreeable women don't we gentlemen in
the comments let the ladies know
no matter how difficult the truth is to
swallow a queen never backs down from
taking the true measure of a situation
or person she doesn't delude herself
into thinking something is more
palatable than it is and she never lies
to herself if she is confused or unsure
she researches and investigates until a
problem becomes clear
this is what Queens do anyway so they
have this big long paragraph at the end
of it and all these things that women
are now I've seen nothing here about
plasma she's agreeable she's a culinary
skills she could be a compliment to a
kid's life none of those things it's
give me an equal or else I'm just going
to stay single I want an equal because I
deserve it because I know my worth
so let's keep going uh we'll close that
one up and we'll go to the next page
over here which are the traits of the
very most desirable and by the way guys
you can go look this up on the
internet's just search for female
dinging strategy Reddit and be prepared
to be disgusted once you go through all
the nonsense that they put over here so
the title of this one is the traits of
the very most desirable women today
okay and there's three main categories
here we've got
being in a movable mover
we've got character and we've got
listening Style so
the lectures that women are receiving
from consuming this
uh very valuable content ladies
is you must become an immovable mover so
that's lecture number one
it opens with okay so everybody here
realizes that the woman should be the
one in charge of how things go
okay well we know how well that works
when women get with guys that don't lead
we also realize that the woman should
not be parenting The Man Okay so we've
got
we've got leaders we've got you know the
unplugged Alphas we've got the guys that
are doing something with their life
putting a dent in the universe or you
know their competent strategic virtuous
captivating funny they're famous you
know
the standard blah blah blah right
all on one side over here but they don't
want
him to be in charge is what they're
telling all these ladies they want them
to be in charge this is like the hashtag
boss girl the hashtag Boss [ __ ] the the
queen sort of narrative so
woman has to be in charge of how things
go but we don't want to parent the guy
so if he's too far down the scale he's a
nerd he's a loser he doesn't have you
know what she's looking for which let's
be honest like
women don't match with 80 85 percent of
guys today when it comes to dating they
just swipe left no no thank you no thank
you no thank you
so they're trying to match with the top
10 15 20 percent of guys so they're
competing for a very small pool of guys
and then they're in this Avenue
eliminating any guy that's a leader that
wants to lead or would you know lead in
a conventional or classic way in a
relationship because she wants to be the
one in charge
so the first piece of advice that
they're giving these ladies over here
the ladies
Bill Burr would have a [ __ ] Ryan with
this one
because you must be an immovable mover
you must be a man basically you must be
a leader
she is the immovable mover
or that or that which moves without
being moved does this have anything to
do with her weight perhaps
she seems trustworthy and reliable
because you know she is how she is and
she went trustworthy and reliable is
that a trait that guys look for in women
let me think
no no women are Beauty objects we like
the looks of a we like the looks of a
beautiful woman we don't we don't think
I mean you want trustworthy and reliable
get a Toyota right
anyway
um precisely but she makes children feel
safe while their parents are immovable
okay it makes men feel safe in a good
way too yeah because we want women to
make us feel I I don't know a single guy
that's worth assault that thinks himself
I want a woman that makes me feel safe
this is a trait that women look for in
men like are you guys starting to see a
trend here they're basically trying to
to to teach or convert conventionally
feminine women into men right they want
they want these women to make men feel
safe really
because if there's a bang in the night
how many chicks do you know that would
jump out of bed and go running
downstairs to deal with the the broken
glass window or or whoever the bad guy
is in the house she nudges him hides
under the covers and says get up and go
deal with it there's absolutely no woman
there that does that so this is just a
big fat lie as most of the rest of this
is too
if you can direct things well you need
to stay in yourself you are a calming
and safe presence while also seeming
adoration worthy yeah after all the two
phrases above are religious oh it's
religious now we're getting into God
nobody says man God is so boring since
he is immovable
um so now they're comparing the these
these Queens are now comparing
themselves to God
aw inspiring because humans you know
okay well they're basically just
describing a dude
a virtuous strong alpha male dude is
what they're describing so let's go to
character
this is the second trade that you must
possess Beyond being
a boss [ __ ] essentially character she
has a character of benevolence even
while staying still in who she is she
respects service professionals that's
the first thing that you have to
understand ladies is respect your
servers when you go to a restaurant
she is kind to animals because that's
the first thing that I think about when
I look at a chick hmm
she looks kind to animals
I'm not looking at Iraq I'm looking at I
bet she's kind to animals that's that's
exactly what I'm thinking right she
doesn't make fun of the unfortunate
well that's like what chicks do right I
mean guys do that they make fun of the
unfortunate sometimes you know that if
you were in a tough situation she would
do the right thing she probably wouldn't
do anything if she was in a tough
situation if we're being honest she's
either going to call her dad or she's
going to lean on her boyfriend or
husband
though she probably they're basically
saying become a man you don't need no
man
if you're in a tough situation you would
do the right thing you got this girl
though she prioritizes herself in all
normal life situations you suspect she
saved a kid from a burning building
great oh that's that's that's rich
how many
how many women run into birding
buildings and carry people out last time
I checked
most firefighters are men and if there's
something heavy to carry out of a
building it's men running in there and
doing it not the gals
oh or take a bullet for somebody weak in
defense us gee why why does this sound a
lot like a man right the character of a
man is basically what they're describing
here anyway I'm not going to keep boring
you with the character area listening
style a Becky listens but a dream girl
has gravitas when a man tells Becky his
deepest Secrets she's sympathetic when
he tells a dream girl his deepest
secrets she is silent forbidden and says
thank you for telling me that before
either saying she needs to think about
that more or make him a serious
observation she then may offer a hug
but it's not an empathetic hug empathy
is when you express I am currently
feeling what you feel but rather a
compassionate hug
oh man
taking care oh hang on
then all the other stuff we know taking
care of your health okay at least I give
them that taking care of your hygiene
Goods so they're not gross hopefully all
that stuff is great but not good enough
to move someone up from Becky category
that's interesting they use the word
Becky to describe that a desirable woman
a dream girl According to some other
posts I saw as an immovable mover who
always seems to be doing precisely what
she wants to be doing her prioritizes
herself in all normal situations but who
your sure has an ironclad enough
character to take a bullet if some yeah
how many women have taken bullets in
history it's only guys that sacrifice
them men are the disposal sex women are
the protected sex when the Titanic hit
the iceberg did all the ladies say hey
guys go ahead you go we'll just step
aside all you guys get off the boat
we'll just wait in here we're the ladies
you know we take bullets this is what we
know women and children's first it's
always been that way it's always going
to be that way they're they're they're
defining the the characteristics and
traits for the most part of a man hey
guys I really hope that you enjoyed that
short clip if you did consider
supporting the creation of content by
checking out my supplement line pinned
in the top comment below of this video
in the comments there's a link to the
unpluggedalpha.com forward slash shop
when you click through you'll be able to
land over here and the entire lineup is
broken down by category that it performs
best in estrogen metabolism fat burning
your foundational Essentials for health
immune Health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code Alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the Subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching I
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out